this is jocko podcast number 159 with
echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
there's a
a terrible feeling
in the gut
that i've only felt
while i was overseas in
iraq
and it's it's
this
deeply distressed kind of
sick feeling
and literally feel it in your gut
literally feel it in your stomach in my
stomach and it's not
it's not the fear it's not fear
it's not it's not the fear of death
because
when you get to a point
when
you kind of accept that death is a
possibility and you're okay with it
then that fear
kind of goes away
and
it's not the
fear of one of your guys being wounded
to kill it's not that either
because even that fear
even that fear
you you kind of get a control of that
fear
because you know you can't dwell on it
because you know if you dwell on the
fear of one of your guys getting wounded
or getting killed then that's gonna
detract from
the very thing that you're supposed to
be doing that will most likely prevent
your guys from being wounded or killed
if you're dwelling on that fear you
won't be doing the things you should be
doing like planning and training and
preparing and inspecting and reviewing
and leading
so even that fear while it's persistent
and heavy
and potent
it's
you have
some level of control over it
but when something goes wrong when
something
happens
and
you're responsible and the burden of
command settles down with its mantras
monstrous weight on top of your
shoulders
because there's no one else to blame
that's what i'm talking about
and actually i felt it for the first
time really
a little bit during my first deployment
that i did to iraq and my platoon we we
did what we were supposed to do
some things
didn't go right
nothing crazy but mistakes were made and
there was actually back to back to back
missions
with related targets that we were going
after and i was the assault force
commander
and i think one of them i might have
even been the ground force commander so
i was clearly responsible for these
missions and there were some mistakes
made and
my commanding officer
came and
spoke to me about it you know pulled me
aside to point out the mistakes and the
resulting impacts that these mistakes
were going to have
and he wasn't happy i mean he wasn't
he wasn't mad because we had a good
relationship and he was talking to me
just straight
but
he wasn't happy
and you know i kept the calm face and i
took ownership and said hey my fault
this is the things we're gonna do to fix
it you know
but
even though i kind of kept a calm face
in front of him when he left i again i
felt like this wretching in my stomach
that
that i had made some kind of mistake and
and one of the worst things about is
there's nothing you can do like the
mistake happened
you can't go back you can't fix it
and i can't compare that
feeling to anything else really that
i've felt
because because i've never felt anything
else that feels like that and i've i've
talked about it with my friends and
leadership positions
overseas and and like actually the first
time
uh is actually stoner that talked to me
about this this gut feeling
and he had something going on
and
you know he's like he's like you know
that feeling and i was like oh yeah i
know that feeling
and
like i said i've never i've never felt
this
feeling this gnawing feeling in your gut
that's eating you from the inside i i
think you
see it sometimes um if you watch you
know some movies try and capture this
feeling
of where it's basically where someone's
life is falling apart but they're trying
to keep a
facade up that everything's going okay
have you ever seen the movie fargo
no okay i got you on this one
this movie fargo there's a guy and he's
he's a car salesman and he's been
fudging the numbers and then he's
he's he's trying to kill someone there's
all these things are happening and it's
all and he's a very
i would say a very naive person
and
he's you know married and he's got kids
and he's trying to do this stuff that's
not right and he knows it and it's
starting to come apart
and that that's the kind of thing where
you can see it's just eating him from
the inside so i think it's that that
type of gnawing deep feeling where
everything is going wrong and there's
nothing you can do about it that's the
that's the closest i i think i can come
is
is just when things are going so wrong
and there's nothing you can do about it
and i think that that
feeling
that feeling for me
i think that's why number one that's why
i always say combat is humbling
it's because of that feeling right there
where you
something went wrong you couldn't stop
it you couldn't control it you can't fix
it it is what it is
and
that makes it humbling
extremely humbling
and because of that
it made me want to make sure that i did
everything humanly possible to prevent
from that to prevent that feeling from
grabbing hold of me again if if i could
help it
it opened up my mind it made me
it made me always want to listen to
other people's input because i always
said to myself wait if i didn't see what
was going on over here how do i ever
know where my blind spots are
i always think i must have blind spots
somewhere there must be something i
don't want to see something i don't
understand
how can i listen i need to make sure i
listen to other people's viewpoints and
perspectives so that i don't so i can
cover and and yeah cover as many blind
spots as possible
review
other methods and other ideas and other
principles to see
what i could learn from them and when
people raise opposing points to me i
don't object to them
i don't bristle up and it's
it doesn't offend me when somebody says
something that that isn't that i don't
agree with it doesn't offend me at all
in fact i want to know more about it
and
as i as i go through my life i try and
continue to listen i try to absorb
opposing opinions and process them and
i want to just understand them i want to
understand the context of them
i want to understand the perspective of
them
it's it's how i think i'm going to
eliminate as many blind spots as
possible
so when someone would tell me
like a new tactic right a new tactic
when i was in in the teams and someone
said hey we're doing this now
and there's of course when somebody
tells you something new
there's always a part of you that says
that bristles up to it and i
again those humbling situations that
feeling in my gut that i didn't want to
feel
it it pushed that
that ego down
because i actually want to hear what
your idea is i want to hear if this is a
blind spot i haven't noticed i want i
want that idea to work i want to see how
it works i want to see if it works and
sometimes they would work
and it's any and i would learn something
sometimes they wouldn't you know
sometimes
it would reconfirm the reason and then
that person would learn hey the reason
we don't do what you're
wanting to do is because of this
and so now i'm helping them with a blind
spot that they might have
but either way my goal was always to
learn
to
hear other people's viewpoints and
that's the way
i remain today
those other viewpoints are going to make
me sharper i'm going to read things
so that i can see them from other angles
understand things from other angles
they can strike when you
understand something from another angle
you can strengthen your position
or you can leave your position if you
realize that your position is wrong
and and it's going to make me better and
it's making me better not for me not
because i want to be better but for the
people that around me the people up and
down the chain of command
that i'm trying to support them
so i can do my job better as a leader as
a follower
and as a person
and
also
so that i can as much as humanly
possible
avoid that wretched seething
miserable feeling in my guts
so
i was thinking a lot about that and
tonight we're going to explore
some
principles of war
actually called general rules
by this
individual machiavelli this is the
machiavelli nicolo machiavelli this is
the guy that wrote the prince he's
got all kinds of great quotes out there
it's better to be feared than loved if
you can if you cannot be both he's got
never never was anything great achieved
without danger
here's one if an injury has been done if
an injury has to be done to a man it
should be so severe that his vengeance
need not be feared
that's pretty ruthless
here's another one hence it comes about
that all armed prophets have been
victorious
and all unarmed prophets
have been destroyed
and one more quick quote as you you can
you can just google machiavellian quotes
and you'll find a bunch of great ones
men rise from one ambition to another
first they seek to secure themselves
against attack
then they attack others and that's
actually from the prince which is his
most famous book and if you think about
the process of
being a human being
that right there is very accurate and
you can really see that with accuracy
if you overlay that on jiu-jitsu first
you seek to secure yourself from attack
and then you attack others right
when you're rolling at first when you
first start you're just trying to defend
you're trying not to get choked and then
eventually you can stop from getting
choked and you can stop from getting arm
locked and you start trying to attack
those people and arm lock them
so
that's machiavelli and uh if you don't
know anything about him he was an
italian
really a politician and a diplomat
and but on top of that
this was during the renaissance period
and and he's an actual renaissance man
so he was a poet he was a philosopher he
was a playwright he was an author of
books
born in 1469 died in 1527 from 1503 to
1506 he was in charge of the florentine
militia
and when he was in charge of that
militia he didn't like
mercenaries
because he realized the weakness of
mercenaries is that they they're they're
getting paid that's why they're fighting
they're not fighting
from their true belief system so he
raised and recruited a citizen army
and they were well respected on the
battlefield
and
they
fought in some pretty good battles and
won but it didn't last forever
florentine was eventually defeated and
dissolved and machiavelli was accused of
conspiracy and tortured
and i of course whenever i
i go down a lot of rabbit holes but i
went down that torture rabbit hole for a
little while yesterday and they were
pretty brutal about it
but he
they thought he was a conspirator or
whatever he did he even after torture
they couldn't get it out of him they
eventually just exiled him and that's
when he wrote his book the prince which
i'm sure we'll cover
on here at some point this is where you
hear this is where the word
machiavellian yeah you know that's kind
of it usually refers to his book the
prince
and and usually that
word nowadays is used to describe
someone that's kind of scheming and
unscrupulous if like if you look it up
in the dictionary that's it'll give you
a definition along those lines like
someone that's trying to
snake and make things happen happen
but yeah and like i said i'm sure we'll
cover that book at some point but
um
after that he wrote uh
another book which is called the art of
war
and
it's it's definitely a really good book
it's and we will probably parse through
the entire thing at some point but
one thing that's good about it is in the
end of the book
he
part seven of the book and there's yeah
that's the last the last part of the
book
he
basically breaks out the most important
principles from the book which makes it
pretty
easy and straightforward to uh
to talk into it to
explain them
and and then you can get the details on
like i said i'm sure we'll get granular
at some point on it
but
here's what he says
in this book
he's and it's
bear with me a little bit only because
the
the translation is old
i know that i've told you
many things which by yourself you might
have understood and considered
notwithstanding i have done it as today
also i have told you for to be able to
show you better meaning thereof the
quality of this army and also to satisfy
those if there be any whom have not had
the same commodity to understand them as
you
normie thinks that
are other to tell you than certain
general rules
the which you shall have most familiar
which be these which is his way of
saying listen
i wrote a lot of stuff i'm glad you
understood it or at least you say you
did but just in case some other people
can't understand it i'm going to break
it down for you very simply in these
general rules and and like i said the
translation
the translation that that i read of this
book is called the tudor translations by
and it's translated by a guy named peter
whitehorn in 1560
so we're talking like somewhat archaic
language and it's a little bit tricky
you know
to get through but i'll talk through and
we'll get it into an understandable
format
and
there we go so
like i said he says hey look i wrote a
lot of stuff here's the general rules
that you should be most familiar with
here we go
number one
the same that helpeth the enemy hurteth
thee
and the same that helpeth thee herdeth
the enemy
that one's pretty straightforward right
what benefits the enemy harms you and
what benefits you harms the enemy
straightforward i think you know that's
one of those common
uh
principles that across the ages everyone
says and the reason they say that is
because people forget it
people forget
that
if
if if we're
if we can hurt the enemy in any way it's
helping us and anything we do that
benefits us is going to hurt the enemy
yeah so sometimes we forget that
that's why many of these various
cannons of
principles on war
remind us of that because it's an
important fact
number two
he that shall be in war most vigilant to
observe the devices of the enemy and
shall take most pain to exercise his
army shall inner least perils and may
hope most of victory
so what does that mean that means pay
attention that means be vigilant in
observing the methods and plans of the
enemy when you're in war number one
pay attention to who you're fighting
against
understand who they are
andy burke
he was going to do
an
ebi i think it was an ebi match
you know who he was going against yeah
craig jones yeah
you know anything about craig jones
yeah craig jones is savage
andy you know he's he's
awesome but we know we're up we're
training we're training hard
he goes and competes against him
and loses fast yeah why'd he lose he
lost because well number one because
craig jones is awesome
and you know what andy's real good at
he was good at all of jiu jitsu but he's
got real good foot locks got real good
heel hooks he likes to play that game
you know it's training with me training
with dean lisch
and so he's rolling in didn't know much
about craig jones in fact he didn't know
anything about craig jones oh dang he
just said oh yeah he's good whatever
yeah not not not in a disrespectful way
right but you ever heard somebody say um
like when they say hey what what
what do you think about your opponent's
left hook or whatever right or they say
ground impound and they say i'm not
worried about my opponent
it's what i'm gonna do it's not what
they're gonna do you know what i mean
and i don't mean that in a bad way i'm
not trying to say andy was cocky right
but andy's thing was like look you know
i do jujitsu yeah that was his approach
yeah like i do jiu-jitsu and hey and
also there's a little bit of like hey
well you might go against this guy but
he might get hurt or you might have this
or whatever you know what i mean so
right and it was a tournament as well so
you can't really get focused on one guy
you're going to be fighting three or
four guys in one night you just got to
get your jiu-jitsu game up yeah
so
andy rolls in
and
he he went right into craig jones game
in seconds
and
and the other thing was
andy's super relaxed like i mean he's
he's relaxed anyways so he's like oh
okay this is you know we're just going
to do some jiu jitsu and
it'll escalate over time and eventually
you know something will you know we'll
get to that point and whatever
and he goes in and boom
and goes right into like one of craig
jane craig jones is like really good
moves just goes right into it yeah for
him
and you know i was bummed
and obviously andy's bummed but
didn't do any
you know we me i should have been like
hey man let's look at your opponents
let's check out their game because if
you just know you know how it is if
you're aware of someone's game you can
definitely mitigate it you can't defeat
it i'm not saying he could defeat craig
jones but he would have been he wouldn't
have fallen into that in a matter of
seconds he would have been oh this is
his move there i need i know what to do
to at least mitigate the first attack
the second attack right
if you don't do that
you're gonna you're gonna have problems
and and he got and then he came back and
we and he's like he's like yeah oh that
guy's good
so props to my boy craig jones you beat
my
my boy
uh hopefully you guys will meet again
one day and you're gonna he'll get
another go and he'll know your game a
little bit better but
bottom line is
study your opponents
study your opponents now can you go too
far with that yeah you can because some
people think oh i wish that happens
sometimes when the ufc someone will miss
wait or they'll get hurt and they'll
throw a new opponent i wasn't ready for
that guy had been training for a striker
now you're putting me up against a
grappler or whatever yeah
so you know uh sarge this is pretty cool
sarge who was a really good who was and
is a really good wrestler he's also jiu
jitsu now but
he was he said when he would train
for wrestling you know because he was a
high school wrestler at poway which if
you know anything about wrestling in
california or actually in america you
know poway high school has a like real
dominant wrestling program
and he was a wrestler there as was his
brother but he said when he would train
he would he would picture someone with
no face
and it's because you know when you're in
the high school wrestling scene out here
in california you know the people that
you're going to come up against right in
the tournament you're going to come up
against these six guys and you know that
two of them are good or whatever but
he'd just say nope and then when he
would look at him he's like when i would
look at him before a match i wouldn't
even i just see like a blur just fog in
their face and then he said
once he knew he was going to go against
that guy then he'd look at him and
calculate their face and be like i'm
going to kill this guy
but that's why
his point in that was
he didn't want to get uh
like his mind offset by oh it's not who
i expected it to be right right so he
wouldn't have any expectation on who it
was going to be he was just going to get
in the murder mode
and then when he finally realized that
they're walking out of the map but then
then he'd look at their face and go okay
this is the guy i'm going against and
i'm going to kill him
which for sarge you know that means he
actually
so
observe the methods and plans of your
enemy
absolutely
next part of it is you you have to
endure much hardship and training of
course you got to train hard so observe
your enemy know what they're doing and
then train really really hard and you're
gonna have a greater chance for victory
of course
common sense
next one number three
never conduct thy men to fight the field
if first thou has not confirmed their
minds and knoweth them to be without
fear and to be in good order
for though for thou oughtest never to
enterprise any dangerous thing with thy
soldiers but when thou seest that thy
hope to overcome
so
again we're dealing with some middle
english here i think
you english
linguists people can get at me if i'm
wrong but we're pretty close to middle
english
maybe it's a little late middle english
but we're in the ballpark so what is he
talking about there
never lead your soldiers into an
engagement unless
you are assured of their courage
and then he actually says unless you
know them to be without fear which is a
stretch in my mind because you're going
to have people that are going to be
afraid in fact you can
you're gonna people are gonna be afraid
when they're going into combat 90
something percent a high percentage of
people are gonna have some level of fear
but you do need to make sure that
they're gonna be able to overcome that
fear so if you've got people that are
shaking in their shoes and they feel you
know you think they're not they've not
been tested at all
well then that that could be a real
problem
and then the question becomes okay well
how do you test if someone's gonna be
afraid or not what do you think they do
in the military
with people what do they do what to make
them not scared to test their fear yeah
how do you test their fear
put them in scary situations they put
them in scary situations in training
make them rappel off the high tower make
them extend to airborne school hey
airborne school
i would say you know of course there's
there's
some level of some things that you need
to learn in airborne school but you're
basically
i mean you can literally throw a sack of
potatoes out of an airplane with a
parachute on and it's going to land up
pretty much okay most of the time and
that's what you do when you go to the
school you learn the proper
exit procedures when i went to airborne
school it's like hey here's the actual
procedures here's how you land you're
floating down you don't have much
control over your parachute
so there's not a lot to learn
technically it's not like a major skill
set i mean it's a let me put it this way
it's a three-week school right it's not
like
it's not it's not a long intensive
school about learning how to
pack parachutes or even how to maneuver
yourself through the air because there's
only so much you can do
so what is it that's important about
airborne school what's important about
airborne school is you're going to
overcome the fear of jumping out of a
damn airplane
that's important that's why an airborne
you go go talk to the 82nd airborne
division of the 101st airborne division
those guys are awesome
and they have that little thing that
they've all done
that has put them they've been screened
out a little bit because some people are
going to be afraid so yes that's what
you do you make people do hard scary
things i mean in the seal teams it's the
same thing what do they do you're going
to learn how to parachute then you're
going to parachute at night they're
going to parachute at night into the
water
then you're going to jump out of a
helicopter at night
at you know 20 feet into the darkness
and with a boat and you're going to rig
that thing up and you're going to dive
at night and you're going to swim at
night in the open ocean like oh you're
just going to go that scares some people
for some reason it never really scared
me yeah
i have no fear of sharks
let me rephrase that i have no fear
that a shark is randomly going to bite
me like if i was in the water and there
were sharks i'd be scared yes
and i know that there's sharks in the
water so that you guys should be scared
but i don't know i feel lucky yeah i
feel like sharks don't really want to
eat meat very much they'd rather eat
like someone like you
well i guess if you're on a surfboard i
guess that increases the chances from
what i understand yeah yeah cause you
look like a seal sure like a like a sea
animal seal so that's what you do you
put people in situations where they're
going to be afraid you know and this is
something that
i think
everyone should do if you have a job
that's going to cause stress you want to
put people in stressful situations so
that's how you test that fear and again
you're not going to
remove the fear from people what you
want to figure out is can they overcome
the fear that's what you want to figure
out
um what else you say know that they're
organized
never make an attempt
unless you unless you see they hope for
victory
so you gotta convince if you're telling
your guys like hey we're probably going
to lose yeah yeah you don't say that you
say look it's going to be hard but
there's a chance we can take this you
know what i mean
you got to get them in that attitude not
the attitude of like oh we're just going
to lose we're just going out here for no
reason yeah
don't let that happen yeah
number four
it is better to conquer the enemy with
famine than with iron
in the victory of which fortune may do
more than valiantness
that one's pretty self-explanatory it's
better to defeat the enemy by hunger
than steal you know it's better to let
him starve than have to go and fight him
and then he says in such a victory
the fortune like your luck counts more
than valiantness which is
cool understandable
this is one of those things where
you've heard me say before
the best victories are the victories
where the person doesn't even know that
you're fighting them that's the best
victory and then if you can if you can
maintain your ego after you win and you
don't gloat then they never even didn't
even register it yeah right they didn't
know they're in a fight they didn't know
they're in a fight that's what you want
this is very similar but but this is
this part i'll
throw a little back at it in such
fortune victory counts more than
valiantness
yeah good fortune's going to help but
guess what we're going to make our own
luck
right we're gonna make our own luck
that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna and we're gonna make bad
luck for the enemy we're gonna dry up
rivers we're gonna damn rivers so they
can't grow food
that's what we're gonna do
so we're gonna cut off
supply chains
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
make we're gonna make fortune
favor us
number five
no purpose is better than that which is
hidden from the enemy until you have
executed it boom
pretty straightforward no plan is better
than that
which you have concealed from the enemy
until the time you execute it
no doubt
true in life
true in business true in jiu-jitsu
that's what just essentially the element
of surprise is a surprise
if you
if you if your enemy doesn't know what
you're going to do yeah and then you're
done and they go oh that was a nice arm
lock yeah or wow you really took over
that market share and i didn't see it
coming yeah yeah if you don't see it
coming that's really it right they see
it coming from a mile away it's like uh
yeah you can still do that sometimes
dean does that yeah but yeah we talked
about that but he does different things
though like yeah yeah yeah
he'll like many many steps yeah yeah
yeah he'll tie up your defenses while
it's on when you when you see the
incoming he ties up all your defenses
like as it gets close
number six
to know in the war how to understand
occasion and to take it helpeth more
than any other thing
to know in war
how to understand occasion and take it
helpeth more than any other thing
what does that mean that means you
one of the best skills you can have
is knowing how to recognize a good
opportunity in war or in life and take
advantage of that opportunity
that is more beneficial than anything
else and you know what the biggest and
most blatant example where you see this
well your kids aren't old enough but
with kids
just kids
kids have so much opportunity in life
yeah
and they just don't take advantage of it
like they should yeah
right yeah
yeah i could see how that could be for
sure but i think that's because they
have hard times
connecting now and then the future you
know i guess that's the thing
yeah there's no doubt that they have
there's no doubt that they have that
athletes
real good athletes same thing they have
all this potential yeah
anytime someone well not any time
oftentimes somebody that are some people
that are given a gift yeah it's just
given to them they don't have to work
for it they don't want to take advantage
of it they don't see the opportunity
they don't take advantage of the
opportunity yeah whatever that skill set
is
yeah because yeah almost like um you
know when you give a kid a gift versus
or money versus if they earn it yep i
think you covered that in a way where
your kid yeah that's that's way covered
in way of the warrior kid yeah so when
you earn it it's like you know the hard
work sort of it takes and you kind of
appreciate it and then whatever comes
out of that but yeah if it's given to
you you just
you run the risk of squandering it for
sure
especially when the going kind of gets
rough you know
yeah no doubt
next
nature breedeth few strong men
the industry and the exercise maketh
many
what does that mean that means you know
nature makes very few
strong brave men
but hard work and training makes many
boom
you gotta work for it
yeah you want people to be brave you
want people to be
have courage
make them strong
make them work hard
that will absolutely increase their
bravery remember that question we got
asked a while ago about how do i make my
unit
guys in a military military how do i
make them proud
how do i increase their level of pride
train hard
they will get physically stronger they
will get mentally stronger and from that
they will
start to take pride in themselves and
pride in themselves as a unit
eight
discipline
may do more in war
than fury
figured you'd like to yeah i kind of
like that one discipline counts more
than fury in war
discipline counts more than fury in life
i'm not discounting emotions
i'm not doing that because you can't
because sometimes man
people's emotions they get they will
carry them through a really tough time
period that's why in discipline equals
freedom in the field manual i talk about
how you got to use them both yeah it's
logic and you got to use emotions
and when sometimes when emotionally it
doesn't make any sense or you're going
to break emotionally you've got to go
with the logic of the situation like i
got to drive through this yeah and vice
versa sometimes the logic is like this
makes no sense whatsoever you have to
turn to the emotional side
but
discipline he says may do more and he's
right it's not 100 it's like discipline
because if you have people that are just
disciplined but they have no heart they
have no emotion how good are they
they're not that good yeah they're
they're not they're not as good as the
person that has both
there's not as good as a person that has
discipline and a little bit of fury
they can kind of get crazy when they
need to but in mma you see this
you'll see someone when they're young
and they'll lose some fights because
they'll they'll sit someone down or
whatever and then they'll just go crazy
trying to catch them they'll get caught
in a triangle yeah
you have to maintain your discipline
even during the the actual battle you
have to maintain your discipline
you can't let the fury get a hold of you
yeah too much discipline fury
disciplined fury yeah you know the
balance you watch the cyborg fight right
the reason why
the newness yes so this is what it
seemed like it's fast but this is what
it looked like where cyborg landed like
a solid one and amanda nunes
as a response unleashed fury like some
legit fury fury
but it was discipline fury because when
she started landing hard ones she didn't
like over commit it was like really
balanced you know she looked great but
there was some there was a lot of fury
fury
like it wasn't like all just open
calculated like punches it was there was
fury but tim kennedy someone's like uh
the ufc
tweeted out like
she's throwing hay makers and tim
kennedy's like those aren't haymakers
cause every single one of them hit yeah
they were full punches from amanda that
were nailing cyborg right in the head
yeah and most of the time like five
times in a row you don't you don't
normally see five
punches land yeah it's especially not
punches that are thrown with that much
fury
yeah
you can kind of tell when like you see
like their their uh feet when they're
you know throwing punches like you could
there's like a huge forward lean if
they're haymakers there's like these
huge forward leans and they're usually
pressing forward like fully but when
they're like disciplined there's like
that you see you can see the balance
like they'll back up just a little bit
you know
yeah it's good
so good yeah so that's crazy
discipline
may do more
than fury so you know what make sure you
have some discipline in their life all
right next one number nine
when any depart from the enemy's side
for to come to serve thee
when they be faithful they shall be unto
thee
always great gains for that power of the
adversaries are more diminished with the
loss of them that run away than those
than those that be slain
although that the name of a fugitive be
to new friends suspected
and old
uh to odious to old odious so what is
he's talking about traders there that's
what he's talking about so when you say
when any depart from the enemy side to
come serve you so when when people
leave the enemy and they come to serve
with you they're going to be more loyal
and
they're a great they're a great
acquisition
and
actually he's saying that people that
leave
the enemy and come to your side are more
powerful for you than people that you've
killed
and
they're they have more value
the when they come aboard your team
they're going to be suspected you know
that the old the your team is going to
look at them with like a cautious eye
and the team that they left are going to
hate them yeah they're gonna hate them
that was weird when sultanatson was
saying that when they would capture
the russian turncoat soldiers that were
now fighting for the nazis
as soon as they spoke any russian they'd
kill him
that was that was a pretty scary thought
so this is very accurate from that
perspective yeah like if you're a trader
we're not even going to give you a
chance we're just going to kill you
yeah
wait so who wait
so the russians
the russians didn't kill him no so there
was a whole group
of russian soldiers
that turned against stalin and turned
against russia and started fighting for
the nazis yeah and so when the russians
would capture those
what they consider to be traitors as
soon as they heard a soldier speaking
russian they'd kill him
the nazis
they were they were russian soldiers
fighting for the nazis was it fossil
that was the guy's name so there was a
german or sorry a russian general that
was the leader of that whole group the
vassal army i think was the name yeah
and so
when the russian
stalin's russian actual red soldiers
would capture these traitors that were
fighting against them now yeah yeah
they would if they heard them speaking
russian they'd kill him
so this is from that perspective it's
accurate
yeah i wonder why they're more valuable
you think because what because or or
loyal he said loyal right too well the
the the russian soldiers that were now
fighting for the nazis they would fight
to the death because they knew that they
were dead anyways right they got
captured yeah like if they got yeah so
yeah they were they would fight even
harder
uh the thing that i'm not sure about
this is well i i guess i agree with it i
i do agree with it
when someone's a traitor you're suspect
of them right yes
you know you're just you're just like
hey you get if you're a tutor you're a
traitor i'm suspect to you so it's going
to take a little time for me to actually
trust that you really came to my side
yeah
but i guess like when you think about
just like how you said you know they
know they're dead anyway kind of thing
where it's like okay let's say mean you
were enemies whatever and one of my guys
goes to you and says hey i give up
i'll i'll help you i give up you're like
okay he gives up i get it yeah and let's
see what he has to offer kind of thing
but i suspect yeah but you're suspect
but let's say
so a guy in your team used to be on my
team
and i know that i'm pissed at that guy
yeah and then he gives up now to me
to my guys like like i see him or
whatever and he's like i give up i'll
help you oh no no no you don't give up
you're dead yeah so it's like that like
are you saying they know they're dead
anyway what the russians did to the
vassal soldiers yeah so oh you traded
okay cool you're dead and that makes
sense right so that's probably why they
have to be loyal because it's either
loyalty or death you know they can't
give up anymore if i am not a traitor i
can give up and get bpow be whatever i
can i can give up i have that option
traitor who already made the trade he
doesn't have that option that's why he's
loyal he has to be like at a minimum
he's going to fight to the death yeah
and it's interesting too that
traders are you know in the business
world because in the business world
you know there's everyone's always
recruiting there's limited number of the
human capital limits
in the world and we can only get so many
people
that can do this job
and if you have skills in that job
you're getting recruited all the time
and so
that's that hurts when they leave
and that's why and and just to kind of
close the loop on this when they leave
almost all the time the reason the
reason that they're leaving is because
of leadership
or i should say lack of leadership
inside their organization so if you have
a
if you have a problem hanging on to
people
in your organization it's most likely
a leadership problem not a comp problem
not a
midlife crisis problem for the employee
it's a leadership problem
because good good people will stay with
good leaders and if there's not good
leaders they're looking for another job
they're looking for another way they're
looking for another opportunity
makes sense leadership leadership
leadership
get some
number ten
better it is in pitching the field to
reserve behind the first front aid
enough
then to make the front bigger to
disperse the soldiers
what that's saying is
it's better to keep your reserves just
behind them keep some reserves just
behind the front lines
rather than spread out
your reserves and take on a bigger front
try and hold more area it's better to
you know this is prioritized right keep
your keep your focus of effort even with
your reserves keep focus of effort keep
them
consolidated so you can utilize them
well
next up number 11
he is difficultly overcome
which can know his own power
and the same of the enemy
okay
let's that was almost like a a yoda type
he is difficultly overcome so what we're
saying there is
it's hard to overcome someone who
knows how to recognize or knows and
understands his own power and the power
of the enemy so does that mean know your
strengths and weaknesses
that's what it means
yes since who says that right yes
something about yes
deal definitely
number 12
the valiantness of the soldiers availeth
more than the multitude
sometimes the situation helpeth
more than the valiance okay so what
we're talking about there is that the
bravery of the soldiers is worth more
than the number of soldiers you have
makes sense if you have
brave
courageous soldiers
they can take a lot more and they can do
a lot more than people or soldiers that
are afraid so you want brave soldiers
and then it says
the sight what does it say that
sometimes the situation helpeth more
than the valiance so even that what
trumps the courageous and what trumps
the bravery is what's the what's the
terrain situation you know what's the
environment that you're in
what are the rules of the game
what are the rules of the game that
you're playing because if you if you
know the rules
you're going to be in a a much better
situation
the uh this happens in jiu jitsu right
yes because the rules are always a
little bit different there's no unified
set of rules in jiu jitsu yeah there's
some close but there's no unified set of
rules and sometimes someone will lose
simply because they don't know the rules
yeah and then once you know the rules
you got to train to the rules yes like
ebi yes
ebi you have those positions that you
start up in if you're in overtime you
start in spider web you start on the
back right right if you don't if you
don't if once you know those rules then
you got to practice those positions so
you can finish the arm lock so you can
finish from the back or you can escape
from either one of those two yeah if you
don't know that you don't practice it
because like
for instance
i'm pretty good at finishing on arm lock
pretty good at finishing an arm lock
sure
on the back i normally transition from
the back to another position
so
i would if i was going to an ebi
tournament i'd have to go and focus on
what that rule set is and make sure i
know how to win from that position yeah
yeah fully yeah big one is the
submission only versus points so if
people like let's say they spend 10
years competing with
points
in the tournaments you know then they go
to submission only with a guy who's only
trained in submission only he's gonna
out you know have an advantage yeah in
all these different yet different ways
because certain rules don't apply some
do
yeah and the terrain part
man
this is this is
it took me a while to understand this in
my
navy career
how important terrain is
and now it's so obvious
but when you're maneuvering on the
battlefield if you know how to read
terrain well
you have a complete advantage over the
enemy complete advantage over the enemy
you should be paying attention to that
terrain studying maps looking at it now
they have all these
you can you can simulate the earth right
it's a google maps like a high speed
where you can get down at eye level and
you can walk the terrain and really
understand what the visibility is like
that's the kind of that's that's you
should you got to take advantage of
those tools you got to understand the
terrain you got to understand the
terrain that you're going into in the
business world
go got to go into a company
understanding what the situation is
there
when you get hired into a new company
you want to know the terrain you want to
know who's got the clout
you know
you want to know who the movers and
shakers are
you want to know what things are off
limits and whatever
yeah
i want to know who's buying
like you know how they do so you know
people always say this is a billion
dollar industry right like that kind of
stuff like oh is it you know how's the
what's the need for your
product i'm remembering because i watch
shark tank this is what they always ask
what was the uh was this a particular
product no no everyone like pretty much
that's one of the things like they ask
or they say they'll be like oh yeah this
is like
a million how you know a million people
own pets you know and all these pets
need this you know so you see i'm saying
so they kind of they got another terrain
in that way yeah that's true they don't
know how many people uh have pets then
they don't know how many people gonna
buy that shampoo you know so you gotta
know that one
dude shark tank we maybe we should just
do a leadership show about shark tank
what you've learned from shark tank sure
next up
number 13
new and sudden thing
make armies afraid
slow and accustomed things be little
regarded of them
therefore make thy army practice and to
know with small fights a new enemy
before thou come to fight the field with
him
middle english coming at you so what
what is that
what basically what we're saying here is
number one new and surprising things
frighten armies
new and surprising things frighten
people
so
on the opposing to that customary and
expected things
they can handle
so what do you do how do you do how do
you how do you
properly mitigate that
therefore you practice
and you fight small engagements to get
them experienced
before you go to
battle on the big battlefield with them
with the enemy
that's what you do train hard don't dive
right in get them used to the new
technology
that's what you do
this is another good one with kids right
you throw your kid into this scenario
that they haven't been into before you
give them a little taste of it
oh yeah this is uh this is exposure
therapy once again
i get asked on the warrior kid podcast i
get asked every
like every day i get at least one
question from a kid
that's i'm afraid of what do i do
and i i
i usually wait two or three podcasts
before i answer the same question again
because it's kids they gotta get the
repetition they gotta get the reps in
yeah
but it's exposure therapy you're afraid
of something cool do a little bit of it
then do a little bit more and that's
unknowingly what i did in a way the
warrior kid won
with him overcoming his fear of the
water i didn't know that that was a real
thing not until jordan peterson this is
called exposures therapy yeah i guess i
need to talk like kermit the frog to
imitate jordan but
but he's like yeah that's exposure
therapy yeah oh okay
next
number thirteen
on to number 14.
he
that with disorder followeth the enemy
after that he is broken will do no other
than to become of a conqueror a loser
if you pursue a routed enemy in a
disorganized manner
victory will be lost and you'll become a
loser keep it under control allah amanda
nunez right sure she had the victory and
you ever seen that that one real quick
clip
and i forget who the fighter is that
that is in ufc
the guy takes a body shot and he keels
over like he's about to like go down and
the dude comes running in swinging yeah
the dude that's keeled over like he's
hurt just crack
he wasn't hurt he was just faking it
yeah i think he was hurt talk about
scott
yeah maybe he was hurt but he wasn't
hurt as bad as he right right functional
apparently apparently
he knocked the dude out yeah it was
the last thing his his nickname is drago
i know that it's interesting that that
stuff doesn't happen more often
it's like trick football plays yeah how
come more trick football plays don't
happen because they lose their trickery
element of it and sometimes there's a
lot of risk involved there's more risk
than like a traditional play a lot of
times yeah
yeah and it's like like the rope i don't
remember that with the rope-a-dope oh
like
yeah yeah you essentially like act like
you're kind of hurt or tired or whatever
and then they punch themself out then
you get them but yeah
yeah
yeah you got to be careful on that kind
of stuff so
when you do have your enemy
on the run
don't go after him crazy
keep it under control yeah there's a
play in football called the reverse
right and i thought that because you
just said why don't they run
because you know i didn't play football
yeah and when you see the trick plays
yeah then you think well that seemed to
work pretty good why don't they do that
stuff more often yeah
yeah okay so here's the common trick
play right they um the quarterback does
a sweep right do they get to the running
back that runs on the outside and then
the running back oh he stops before he
reaches the line of scrimmage he stops
and he throws the football not to a
receiver but to the quarterback
who ran a route on the other side of the
field and because no one's going to
cover the quarterback he's not a
receiver you know and now he's wide open
to pass now he's wide open what's that
called
uh
we called it pass back to the
quarterback so if you're like 38 sweet
pass back to the point okay but
i can see where there's risk in that one
yes because that's a running back
so you gotta nail that throw which is
really hard for running back typically
but i'd say the the one that would
always work
is
in pop warner anyway it would always
work is the reverse it's essentially
like you do a sweep everyone's running
this way to block for this running back
everyone except for the one tight end or
the wide receiver whatever who's coming
this way and the running back hands it
off to him going this way so he's full
speed running this way so everyone has
to change direction to chase him
and usually that side of feels wide open
um it works way better in pop warning
younger teams because they don't know
like these these situations like they
don't know they just see everyone
running there and they just sort of go
you know more than a professional
they're gonna be like wait i shouldn't
just be you know
um but
that was one i was like why don't we
just always run the reverse because
every time this is this team that we
played against they'd always run it and
it always i understand why if you ran it
every time well then
then the regular reverse or the regular
play would become the surprise but it
seems like
it seems like you could keep people
guessing a little bit more those trick
plays always see i always look at him
and go i was pretty creative and pretty
good yeah
yeah
i think
you see it
like um kind of like i said like when
you go up in um like skill like you go
into the pros or whatever trick plays
don't work is good they have to be
really advanced trick plays that's when
you have you ever seen like the trick
play that like
where
they like almost walk off the field yeah
yeah and then they like walk over like
there's something wrong with the ball or
something like stand up and they'll be
like no something's wrong and then they
just start running yeah
yeah so even that and then those can
backfire too because they'll be like
if all it takes is one defensive person
to know that hey that ball is in play
right now so they can just sort of walk
over and hit it out of the hand grab it
from whatever they want because no one's
blocking them you know no one's like
everyone it's kind of it's just risky
jack you get more people doing that
they're going to be like oh they're hip
to it anyway it would never work
after a while
number 15
he that prepareth not necessary
victorials to live upon
is overcome without iron
so
um
whoever does not prepare food and
provisions necessary to live is going to
be overcome without any weapons at all
so what does that mean take care of your
people take care make sure you take care
of your logistics
logistics wins wars
and people need to survive
so
do that number 16.
he that trusteth more in horsemen than
in footmen or more in footmen than in
horsemen must accommodate himself with
the situation so
in the ancient times you had cavalry on
horses and you had the infantrymen on
feet and he said if you prefer one over
the other
then you have to put yourself in the
right situation
where it's advantageous
so
that's why it's good to be well balanced
and not really prefer one over the other
but if you do then put yourself in a
situation that's most advantageous to
your style or preference of fighting
but make sure you learn how to wrestle
[Music]
because if you don't know how to wrestle
someone else is going to dictate to you
where that fight's going to go yeah
when thou write
see if in the day there be
coming any spy into the camp
cause every man to go into his lodge
okay so what we're saying is this is
pretty straightforward basic head count
if you want to see if there's a spy in
the camp i would send everyone to their
place you know get a head count no big
deal 18.
change purpose when thou perceives that
the enemy hath foreseen it
what does that mean if you if you think
the enemy or if you perceive that the
enemy knows what you're doing then
change your plan
that's that's what that means pretty
straightforward now
where we don't do that or the reason
most of the time we don't do that is
because of our ego
we got our plan and we're going to stick
to it now this is a total
this is why leadership is hard
because there's a point
where your plan
you got your plan and if you stick to
your plan you can it's gonna work right
and then there's a point where you can
stick in your plan you're sticking with
the plan and it's going to fail because
it's not working
so as a leader this is one of the
hardest things to do as leaders to
recognize like you know what
the plan that i came up with it's not
going to be perfect but it's still going
to work and we're going to go with it
because to try and change the plan
halfway through
is really hard to do
even if you rehearse the contingencies
now if you rehearse the contingencies
properly you're probably gonna be able
to execute your new plan pretty easily
but if you didn't
it's gonna be a problem
so this is one of the hardest things for
a leader to do is to pay enough
attention and then weigh the risk versus
reward because
if you're coming up with if you have
your plan and you're executing the plan
and all of a sudden something changes
it's not quite what you thought you
decide you're going to try and do
something completely different what your
changes that you make on the fly are
going to cause as much confusion as what
the enemy is doing and it's going to be
a real problem
however like this says if the enemy sees
what you're doing and now they're
reacting to it in a proper way and your
plan is no longer effective you have to
be able to
you have to be able to
comprehend that
and discern whether you should change or
not and that's one of the hardest things
really uh hardest decisions for a leader
to make as it's happening
what's worse than that is we have a long
period of time when you start talking
about strategic plans
this is where ego gets more involved
yeah because when i have this plan and
this is what we're going to do
and i'm just going to stick with it and
if it's not working i'm going to do it
harder yeah yeah
so
that's what you want to watch out for
you know there's like some of these um
companies being taken down by online
companies right you got to change your
game plan yeah you know you got to
adjust you got to look at them and say
okay what are they doing where are they
going
you know blockbuster
like like i've said this before
blockbuster could have
could have completely dominated netflix
but what did they do nope we're just
over here hey people are going to keep
coming to our stores yeah you know
there's a certain feeling that you get
when you come into a store and you get
to look at on browse with the movies
it's almost like you get to pick up
popcorn where you can get popcorn at
your house
you know people are going to want to
keep coming into these stores
right no actually they're not they
already have popcorn at their house
amazon delivered it yesterday in an hour
by the way yeah
you're terrain too on that one and yet
they had all the relationships with the
movie places what are those movie
companies called what are they
production companies what's it like
what's warner brothers what is that yeah
production studio yeah they oh they had
studio they got their relationships with
the studios they could have been like
hey we're gonna start selling this stuff
online yeah and they would say well that
doesn't make any sense because the it's
going to be all jumbled up when it gets
downloaded yeah but it's going to get
better we're just playing the long game
yeah it's weird that black instead they
were thinking
you know it's too hard to download a
movie on the internet it's going to be
jumbled up there's gonna be buffering no
one even knew about the netflix invent
buffering no buffering is just an
internet situation
yeah when it has to catch up but do you
remember
five years ago
there was buffering on all kinds of
stuff now there's hardly any buffering
barely any buffering i bet my littlest
daughter doesn't even know what
buffering is she's just streaming
i'm sure she knows what it is but she
has never witnessed it yeah well then
again
you know you get bad service somewhere
yeah get some buffering
they weren't wrong they i mean they were
wrong blockbuster
but
they just
the whole idea of like people like
coming into blockbuster and browsing the
movies and buying the thing is that's
true like we did like doing that yeah
but it's because we didn't have a better
option you know like when you go like
even going to the store sometimes it's
kind of cool and fun you know sometimes
but
most of the time at the end of the day
i'd rather press a button than go to the
store i'd rather press a button too
every single time
yeah
and there's also that thing where
you you're it's a positive feedback loop
right it's an echo chamber i like going
you know two of those people in the in
the c-suite of blockbuster like you know
my wife loves going down and picking out
a new movie with the kids they love
doing that you know someone's like yeah
you know my kids love that too so and my
teenage daughter likes doing it too with
her friends and like you said that's
because there's no other option yeah
your teenage daughter would be rather
being around alone in a room clicking on
the next netflix movie yep popping there
popcorn that got delivered earlier yeah
so
if you
if you are on a strategy and it's not
working you got to recognize that you
need to change it
note to self everyone in the leadership
position pay attention to that one
next up number 20
soldiers when they abide at home are
maintained with fear and punishment
after when they are led to the war with
hope and with reward
now what's that saying is when soldiers
are confined to their quarters
they're kept there by fear and
punishment when they're led to war
they're led by hope and reward
you know fear for me is just not a good
tool for a leader to use period
i'm not saying you never this is i'm not
saying you should never use it right
there should be some element
a little element of fear right just a
little element of fear sure right let me
ask you this do your kids have any fear
of you at all because you seem real nice
yeah
uh they do yeah there's there's at least
enough a healthy
element yeah i mean i would say yeah
healthy but i don't know i don't really
know what the standard of healthy fear
levels are but yeah we agree that there
is a healthy level of fear i agree even
with your kids yes your kids shouldn't
just think that that there's going to be
no repercussions for anything that they
do yeah
your troops should also feel a healthy
level of fear yeah and it's hard to even
use that word because the word is so
negative yeah but there should at least
be a level of like you know what we want
to do that yeah no there's a line with
jocko and you don't want to cross it
yeah there's a line with dad echo
he seems real nice and all cruisy
i think i am a little bit too cruisy
though for sure
so
sometimes you do
have to
make sure people understand that if they
cross the line there's going to be a
problem and my kids definitely
understand if they cross the line
there's going to be a problem yeah that
makes sense yeah it's a real problem it
doesn't surprise me
and it keeps them in check yeah
next up 20 and i'm pretty lenient i'm
pretty cruisy you're actually
surprisingly cruisy and lenient everyone
thinks i'm going to be the
uh great santini you've probably never
seen that movie no yeah
but you don't want to raise your kids
like that
who's the girl well you don't want to be
all militant and impose discipline on
your kids
and make them
number one reliant on your discipline
instead of their discipline i don't want
to
you don't want anyone like that you
don't want your team to be like that
where they're reliant on you barking at
them to tell them what to do you don't
want that then they can't function for
themselves
you don't want your kids to be that way
either you want your kids to think you
know what i need to make a good decision
i could slack off or i could do what i'm
supposed to do i'm going to do what i'm
supposed to do because i know it's going
to be beneficial in the end as opposed
to i'm going to do what i'm supposed to
do only because i'm afraid that my dad's
gonna yell at me or ground me or take
away my computer or smash one of my
favorite toys yeah
yeah you don't you i mean like the
assumption i think anyway would be that
you're like more drill sergeant
i'm not even drill sergeant i'm never
i know
you're not but i think it's like when
you look at you or maybe if you just
said like one or two sound bites and
you're like oh he's joking there's
recordings
many recordings of when i used to
debrief
seal platoons okay and i'm gonna try and
get some of those and what is it they're
just well it's it's definitely i could
see it's not drill sergeant e yeah
but it's definitely direct and can be
pretty harsh from time to time so like
that's what i understand people would
probably but but that was usually it'd
only be that way
if somebody really did something
egregious because most of the time
they'd be like hey what do you think
what were you thinking about over here
debrief me on that you know what i mean
so
yeah and it's all contextual too like
you know i guess it's kind of natural
like let's say i heard that right i
didn't really know you or nothing and i
heard that and be like okay he's real
direct and real real strict and like all
this stuff so it's just natural to be
like oh because he's that kind of guy
you know rather than kind of the
understand the nuance like okay he's
talking to these people at this time
yeah and then versus but then again then
that opens it up who knows then how
you'd be so you just your mind just sort
of wants to just attach yeah what they
have witnessed you know to everything
yeah well even drill instructors aren't
like drill instructors yeah i mean it's
a it's a training methodology yeah
there's a purpose for them to act that
way see and you know that because you've
been around because that type of leader
isn't doesn't function
that type of leader is not good
that type of
person
isn't going to function within a team
yeah
so you can't you just can't be that way
is there a level of intensity sure
do i bring a level of intensity
sometimes yes absolutely yes sir
but
that's not the way to go through life
imposing discipline and fear into your
team
you'll end up with either one of two
things a broken team
that relies on you for their discipline
or a team that mutinies against you and
comes up and kills you yeah frags you in
the as they did in the nom
next number 21
good captains come never to fight the
field except necessity constrain them
and occasion
call them
so what that's saying is good you know
good captains good leaders never enter
into the engagement unless it's
completely necessary
that's that's a great point and this is
one of those things where
if you're in a leadership position you
shouldn't be doing the you shouldn't be
shooting your gun at the enemy you
should be observing your team shooting
the gun and looking to see where the
enemy is maneuvering to yeah this is a
this is about detachment right here
don't get in the mix
stay detached decentralize command let
the team maneuver
let them understand what the commander's
intent is and let them maneuver towards
victory you stay back a little bit and
monitor
go diving in there does that apply to
because you're the one who kind of said
this example to me one time
i forget if it was on here or not but
you're like um
it was about you when your kids
tying their shoes you know yeah let's
say like i don't know you're late for
school or we're running late or whatever
and they're having a hard time tying the
shoes yep you're like let them tie the
shoes don't jump in and be like i'll do
it you know i did say that and i've said
it a bunch of times that's a real simple
example
that's a little bit more towards the
last question or towards the last
discussion that we just got into i mean
if you let your if you tie your shoes
for your kids all the time they don't
learn how to time yeah and furthermore
you literally are taking away their
opportunity to learn some fine motor
skills at that moment this is not the
same as that
this is
this is on a broader
perspective your team is doing so your
team is in a fire fight
and you pick up your gun you go on the
front line and you start shooting at the
enemy well now who's leading right now
who's looking around yeah this is the
same as you know you're in a business
situation and your team is trying to
come up with a plan and they're arguing
amongst themselves and you jump in there
and start arguing too now you don't have
a good perception of
you should be just standing back
listening to the various arguments take
place i'm not talking about arguments
where people are yelling and screaming
i'm talking about
a discussion where they're arguing
different possible courses of action if
you dive right into those and you start
becoming involved at point-blank range
you lose all your perspective so instead
you step back you don't you don't
you don't go into the field yeah you
don't dive into the argument you step
back and you watch the fight unfold and
then as the fight unfolds you see the
best options because you're at altitude
and you're not
at point-blank range one foot from the
enemy fire
this is just detached decentralized
command
next up
cause that enemies caused that the
enemies know not how thou right order
thy army to fight
and in whatsoever manner that thou
ordainst it
make that the first band be received of
the second and the third
middle english get some what are we
talking about here
well cause your enemies no not so that
means you don't want your enemies to
understand
how you're gonna organize your your army
to fight that's what this is you you
want to confuse your enemy you don't
want them to know exactly what you're
going to do
and then the second part
make it make that the first band may be
received to the second and third i'm
pretty sure i'm not 100 sure but i'm
pretty sure that's just talking about
mutually supporting positions so you
want to set your team up so that they
can support each other
so confuse the enemy don't give up the
plan and set your teams up so they can
help each other once your team once a
team is alone and unsupportable they're
alone
try not to let that happen
in the fight
never occupy a battle to any other thing
then to the same for which thou hast
appointed it if thou wilt make no
disorder
it's a good date it's modern english
appreciation yeah what makes it hard too
is they spell even words that you know
they spell them all differently and just
so you know you're looking at this i
actually
tightened up some of the spelling and
made some of the spelling more modern
because i just couldn't it was harder to
track man yeah it's harder to track
again this this thing was interpreted
from italian in 1560
by was it george whitehead was getting
after the translation
yeah
so um
it just it's it's interesting and this
is the same thing you know i said that
when we did shakespeare don't need to do
more shakespeare but people think oh i
should just understand shakespeare
you're not going to understand
shakespeare it's almost a different
language
so you need to actually
break it down like we're doing with
these
various statements
so
what this one is saying is
don't use
a company don't use uh
don't use a unit
for a purpose other than what you've
assigned it
unless you want to cause disorder
unless you want to cause chaos
so you've got your team they're assigned
to do this let them do that now
obviously that can be problematic
so we need to mitigate that because
there's times when team is going to have
to do something that you
don't want it to do
and
so
i'll give you a little example
when you're doing an assault on a target
you have two elements the base element
and the maneuver element
the base element is going to stay in
position they're going to sneak up on
the target
and then the maneuver elements gonna
sneak over to the flank and then the
base element's gonna start
firing massive firepower at the target
and then the maneuver element after a
little bit will stand up and start to go
through the target they shift fire off
the target
and then you clear the target
so
when i was a young kid in the terms
parking jersey so
we would we would you know like let's do
this yeah so we're gonna hit this target
we're going to do a fire and maneuver on
this target base and maneuver
so what we would do is say okay let's
take all of our heavy machine guns
and put them in the base element
and then the guys with the little
peashooters the little little m16
peashooters
all those guys will be on the assault
because they're light and they'll be
able to maneuver really quickly through
the
get to the target and then go through
the target
makes perfect sense
and i remember the first time i
presented this type of plan to one of
the old guys from nom
he's like no don't do that
why not master chief
this way we have more firepower in our
base and our maneuver guys can maneuver
more quickly
here's the problem
when that maneuver element is going
towards the target what happens if they
get compromised and contacted and now
they're they're they're the ones that
have to lay down their base they can't
get up and move because they're being
shot at so guess who has to move
the base element has to move
and they can't move very well if they're
only getting uh cover fire from little
peashooters
so you keep your integrity of your
squads and you utilize them that way and
it's like oh
so what you want to do
in this situation is you want to make
sure that your elements can are capable
of doing each other's jobs maybe not to
the fullest extent but they at least
need to be somewhat capable so maybe you
put one machine gun in the expected one
extra machine gun in the expected base
element and now you only have a couple
machine guns in the maneuver element but
you got them if you need them
so
i don't 100 agree with that
that being said
you definitely want to let people do the
job that they were assigned to do
makes sense right you've trained them
you've assigned it let's let's try and
keep the plan as it's supposed to be
yeah
to the best of our ability but
we're thinking we're not black and white
here yeah
leadership is not easy
um you know another thing is
when you establish your teams you try
and use those teams for everything if
you can
and again this is a dichotomy because as
much as you want to keep your teams
together
you also have to train them to be split
up and broken up and combined and
mismasked all together and i would
always do this with all my
fire teams so the fire teams would stick
together as much as humanly possible but
guess what i would also train them that
if they were all scrambled up someone
would step up take lead and that'd be a
new fire team
and we'd start making stuff happen
next up
24.
the sodine
accidents with difficulty are remedied
those that are thought upon with
faculty
i had to look up sodine
because i i couldn't even get a clue on
what that one was but it's some sort of
leader or a ruler it's actually a ruler
and this is this is a this is so he's
saying the sodine accidents the
leadership accidents with difficulty are
remedied are hard to fix when leadership
screws up it's hard to fix
those that are thought a pound
with difficulty are remedied
if
you use your head quickly
so yeah there's going to be leadership
problems and they're hard to fix unless
you think
and think quickly
how do you how can you improve your uh
speed of thinking
do you know how you can do that
practice practice so
uh
let's say get experience too right
because experience gives you the
practice yeah it's experience if i've
seen something before
it's i'm gonna know
a thousand times faster how i'm gonna
react to it yeah
if i haven't seen it before i it takes
me a while just to comprehend what's in
front of my face
yeah so
that's why when we train we train
to throw things
okay so first of all when we train we
want to throw things at people
that
different scenarios different things
happening where they start to get
pattern recognition oh i've seen this
type of thing before
on top of that you also want to train
people
what to do or how to react when they've
never seen it before
they've never seen anything like this
before
because if i show you let's say i'm
training you for
well i guess we might as well just use a
jiu jitsu tournament right we just use
jiu-jitsu i'm training you for jiu jitsu
situations right and i teach you how to
defend this and i teach you how to
defend that and i teach you how to
defend that right i teach you how to
defend 10 different things and you get
pretty good at it
i also have to teach you
a broad concept of what to do when
there's something that you don't
recognize
so
hey if the guy grabs your arm i want you
to pull your arm here hey if the guy
starts to go for your neck i want you to
swim your arm your hand underneath and
tuck your chin if the guy starts pulling
towards your back i want you to shift
your leg up and so he can't maneuver
around there so i'm going to give you
exact
steps to execute if you see these things
and then i'm going to say this
if he's doing something you don't
recognize here's what i want you to do i
want you to talk your elbows in i want
you to posture and i want you to control
his hips
oh okay and then you'll start to be able
to recognize what's going on at least
you're going to survive
i want you to detach and step back and
say what's he attacking same thing with
combat
i'm going to train you like hey if he
does this you do that if he does that
you do this
if you have no idea what's happening
here's what i want you to do
get into a 360 degree perimeter
listen right i mean whatever that that
situation is going to call for if you
don't know what's happening like if i
don't know where i'm getting flanked
from or if i don't know where i'm
getting shot at from hey everyone take a
knee get cover
don't just start shooting because that's
going to cause confusion it's also going
to give away our position yeah so what
we're going to do we're going to go into
a 360 degree perimeter we're going to
hold what we got
we're going to
that's our that's our that's our if we
don't recognize what's happening that's
what we're doing so we have standard
operating procedures for things that we
recognize and we actually also have
something to do if we don't recognize we
have a procedure for non-recognition
yeah
yeah which is important it's kind of
like i mean it's different i guess but
it kind of maybe fits in with you know
how people say expect the unexpected
kind of thing so it kind of fits in
there yes
you're essentially trained for
unexpected
yes that's the important part it's not
just expect the unexpected it's have a
protocol for when something unexpected
happens yeah here's what we're going to
do yeah
because a lot of times when something
unexpected i'm thinking jiu-jitsu right
now but it's because that's on purpose
you know like these guys with these
weird games yeah we're tall flexible
guys or something like that they have
these weird games and they'll do stuff
that they know or they kind of rely upon
you not have seen it before like you
didn't see it before so
they can capitalize when you start to
panic you know or when you can you know
if let's say your arm is out here like
um
like there's some leg locks that that
uh require you to kind of try to spin
out of it then they'll catch you with
something else right it's kind of that
so if you
have a protocol that's just like i don't
know whatever the protocol is safety
protocol you know it not only
keeps you safe doesn't it statistically
speaking you know chances are it'll keep
you safe but it'll jam up their game
yeah overall you know especially these
people that they
they capitalize on you panicking and not
knowing what to do you know when you
want to have some kind of a reset
position and i used to use this with
fighters like hey here's your reset
position like just get to here because
you're comfortable there get them under
control control their hips whatever yeah
combat same thing oh you're
you're everyone's confused everyone's
mixed up guys are all over the place
let's get to a reset position in a
building yeah yeah now everyone knows
where we are we get control of ourselves
business
same thing we got we got scenario that
we don't know what's happening you know
what
general quarters like hey we're all
going to go to our normal positions
we're going to stand by because we don't
know what's happening right
so you got to have
not just to expect the unexpected you've
got to have a protocol to follow when
something is occurring that you don't
understand yet
some kind of a reset position
put that in your world
next up
number 25 men iron money and bread be
the strength of the war
but of these four the first two be most
necessary because men and iron
find money and bread but money
and bread find not men and iron
yeah that one's pretty pretty cool
pretty self-explanatory now let me let's
go to a business perspective here
a business perspective here because this
is a this can help people make decisions
in the business world
when you're going to make expen
expenditures when you are going to
invest in something in your company
it is important to assess
whether or not you are investing in
something
that is going to help you build
is going to help you
grow
or if you're investing in something that
is not
so for instance let's say let's say hey
our
our we could either take you know fifty
thousand dollars
and remodel our current office
or we can take fifty thousand dollars
and we can rent this new sub office in
an area that we don't have any um
presence in
so
which one is a better investment like we
don't really need that remodel of our
office this other thing is going to help
us actually grow
so
make sure that the investments that
you're making the first thing you want
to invest in is men and iron
right you don't want to invest in money
and bread money and bread is going to be
gone yeah
and it doesn't reproduce it doesn't
reproduce itself
whereas men and steel is going to get
you more of that bread and iron in the
long run
or sorry bread and money
all right number 26
the unarmed rich man
is a booty to the poor soldier
what does that mean it means that the
unarmed rich man is the prize of the
poor soldier that sort of means it means
it means be armed
and this is the last one number 27
accustomed thy soldiers to despise
delicate living and luxurious apparel
i like that one
what does that mean get your people get
your soldiers to despise delicate living
despise
comfort despise luxurious clothing
that's what i'm talking about they'll be
better soldiers they'll be better people
i understand you feel like i'm talking
to you right now what the connoisseur of
comfort the constitution of comfort you
know he's in my firing line right now
yeah i dig it man i think obviously i
can't disagree with that because dang i
mean
yeah
when you've been uncomfortable for an
extended period of time does it not make
you a better person a little bit yeah it
does there we go yeah
you know the whole idea be comfortable
you've told me the story of you
because i know it doesn't rain a lot
here but you used your kettlebells in
the rain in the other day you've told me
that story two times in a two days in a
row now
sure right yes
yeah today you told me that even jade
your brother came out was impressed by
your determination
commitment so what is it what is it
about that that made you
feel compelled to tell me about it and
be
you know for lack of a better word
pretty damn proud that you went out in
the rain and did a kettlebell workout in
the cold um yes well
yeah it's strong it and how did you feel
inside well it felt strong when it was
over you feel better yeah this is it
well yeah it makes me stronger i'm
asking you real questions right now it
might seem like i'm joking but it's
actually real you know why because this
is a little step for you and there's
other people that are listening that
would
benefit from hearing how taking this
little step away from comfort really
truly made you
mentally and physically better go echo
charles all right well
the
where can i start on that one okay so
okay yes i go outside
i had a workout planned it's raining
raining kind of hard too by the way and
it's kind of cold the kind you gotta
wear like a lot of clothes you know so
yes i go and do the whole workout hard
too and yes my brother was like dang
that's some dedication whatever but yes
so the feeling is yeah that i'm actually
strong now you know it's like basically
when you when you break down it's like
now you're strong and you're not weak so
weak would be like just the littlest
thing will throw you off your plan you
know a little thing because you can't
because you're so used to comfort where
you're so used to like the clothing
thing i mean yeah that's kind of weird
too like if if you always got to be
wearing like nice clothes otherwise like
you're kind of you don't go out or
something i don't know
but it's kind of it seems like the same
the same concept but yeah if you can
endure that stuff and then how do you
feel when you're done
better yeah did you feel better after a
workout in the cold rain where you went
and got after then you
would have had it been just normal 70
degrees in sunny socal yeah a little bit
but i feel like
um
it's it was just more of a psychological
thing which does help big time because
now you know that rain you just prove to
yourself that rain cold whatever is not
an excuse
do you see what i'm saying i will be you
40 years raining cold was an excuse no
more no more no more well here's the
thing you're going to battle
you know what's funny here's a good
here's a good expression you used to say
in the damn sparkling debris
when it was raining and cold you know
we'd say good operating weather
but it was like uh it was kinda it's
true
it's definitely true because
when it's raining and when it's cold
guess what the people that are you know
on watch
your enemy guess what they're doing
they're they're hiding yeah they're all
bundled up and warm so that makes it
easier for you plus there's noise
from the rain which camouflages the
noise that you're making walking through
the the jay
or the woods or whatever
but that's always a good one whenever
it's whenever it's crappy weather
i always i always say to myself good
operating weather yeah kind of smile but
we used to say to each other is this
like
you can't complain about it you just
look at your buddy as like when you when
the door of the
of the helo truck you know what a helo
truck is no back in the day we didn't
have a lot of money for budget and so
we'd pretend that we were in helicopters
and we'd be in the back of big trucks
and they just drive out in the middle of
the desert open up the helo truck and
open it up open up the door we'd jump
out like we just got out of a helicopter
little did we know
that when the war actually came we would
be using vehicles we used vehicles all
the time we i
rarely
rarely used helicopters in iraq
in afghanistan they use helicopters a
lot more
but for me in iraq
foot patrol and helo trucks but we
didn't have to call them hello trucks
anymore now we just called them trucks
sure
but
when you're in a helo truck
in 1994 and you get driven up into the
wherever
and the door of the helo truck opens out
opens up
and it's raining
and it's cold
and as you're getting out of the truck
your last moment to communicate out loud
to everyone you hear someone go good
operating weather yeah and you're like
yeah it is this is gonna suck yeah
yeah and it makes sense so like yeah if
you're
used to being uncomfortable right or if
you like despise comfort however you put
it yeah um it's not me yeah machiavelli
said it despised comfort despising
comfort
essentially you're getting comfortable
with being uncomfortable you know how
they say that right they do they do man
so yeah that's what they're doing so
that's why yeah yeah just improv
basically at the end of the day improves
your chance of success you know may uh
roadblocks of discomfort come about in
the future that's what happens indeed
and i i
i think that not only will the rejection
of comfort make better soldiers it'll
make better people so yes as you said
get out of your comfort zone
impose discipline and discomfort on
yourself
and you
will become
a better person
okay and that wraps up machiavelli for
now
but echo speaking of um
getting out of our comfort zone and this
is gonna be a little dichotomy here
but getting out of our comfort zone to
become better
what recommendations do you have for us
to make that happen like i said there's
gonna be a dichotomy here okay because
what do we have
well
well there's a lot of things you have
but but yes so uh being the connoisseur
of comfort
and
so you're kind of the connoisseur of
discomfort really in a way i don't know
about that here's the thing though
people
i don't think about it much though yeah
you know what i mean i'd have to be like
actively thinking about it about what
discomfort just about anything oh i'm
just over here doing what i'm doing yeah
you know what i mean just with
discomfort
capability i don't care
i don't care
there's that old viking saying
he's like the rain is cold
and the old viking says how can the rain
be cold
right
the rain's not cold
yeah but i don't know i don't get it how
can the rain be cold
if it's cold then it's cold no it's cold
to you when it hits you the rain itself
isn't cold it can't that's it's a play
on words
yeah yeah that's another good thing to
think yourself
another good thing you think yourself
you only get wet once
yeah i've talked about that before yeah
you you're waiting to go across the
river you're looking for the best spot
you're like oh
no you know just get wet you're only
going to get wet one time once you're
wet you're wet doesn't matter again it's
true so suck it up the comfort thing is
it's all it's like context is a huge
has a lot to do with it remember how i
told you that time where it's like you
know how sometimes you can just fall
asleep on the floor i know or in the
beach i don't know but then sometimes
you get in your on your couch or on your
wherever and you just can't fall so you
can't get comfortable enough you know
interesting because
you expect the comfort is what i'm
saying but if you don't have any
comfortable expectations it's like you
just be you're just comfortable it's
almost like you're just appreciative for
any kind of comfort but if you expect
mass comfort
it's like you can't get enough comfort
you know because you just expect more
it's weird so like
like um okay so you know you have
experience with cold water
right getting into hit the surf whatever
so when you're there how hard is that
it's not not right you're just like
we're just doing it yeah this is what
we're doing this is we're whatever it's
cold it sucks whatever even if it's
but
here's the uh this is me keep in mind
but still i think it holds
true so i'm getting in the shower the
other day it's cold here
california weather
tell that to pete
well pete's gonna understand because
this would probably happen to him too so
listen you know how you're cold you know
you like it's just sort of cold right so
i'm i'm about to take a shower and
you know the kind when you turn on the
shower it's not just doesn't come out
all warm
it takes a few seconds or whatever so so
i turn it on and it hits me oh because
you take warm showers
that day
anyone understood anyway the cold water
like kind of hit me and i was like oh
there's no way i could bear going
underneath that shower like before it
gets warm no way man no way
but then and then whatever it heats up
but i'm thinking like nah like
jocko guys go in that cold surf like for
a long time and so then i'm thinking no
it's totally in context you know like if
i
let's say a minute before i walked in
the shower i was like i'm gonna take a
cold shower right now doing it literally
the same exact time
i could do it you see what i'm saying so
it's like a mindset kind of thing
a track even aside from the training of
course i would say this and the reason
that i can't
me it's just like blank
no bro it's not here
maybe it is bro but no i don't know
think about this when you get out of bed
right well then again your routine is
different
but yeah let's say you're just sort of
you know i have an actual ice bath yeah
but that's different too bro you used to
take ice bath all the time okay but
that's what's up i'm saying like what if
you get i don't know out of bed or
you're just cruising at home
which you probably don't do but let's
say you were and it was just cold the
kind like oh i'm pretty cold right now
i should put on a jacket right now a
study whatever that's how cold it is
right here right not freezing but just
i'm cold right now uncomfortably cold
and then let's say your son comes with a
cup of ice water and dumps it on you
uh-huh right uh-huh
how would you sneak up on me
so you're saying
okay maybe he didn't sneak up on you
maybe he's i don't know but let's say he
poured ice water on you okay you're just
telling me that you're like whatever
that wouldn't
you'd be viking like can be like oh like
i don't know it's not cold well i tell
you if he was looking for a reaction
from me i wouldn't give it right
okay which i did i dig it there would be
a grappling match happening real quick
though yeah so uh yeah and i understand
it was an attack
okay so that aside i'm talking about the
actual yeah
cold water hitting you yeah yeah yeah
but so it's not nothing but oh it's
something but okay it's something
but that compare that experience to if
he came up to and say hey dad i have
this cup of cold water it's kind of cold
right now do you think you can like
endure this right and you're like oh
yeah i can endure it do it and he did it
i'm not saying that would be nothing or
something i'm saying that those two
experiences are different okay yeah
so this is the uh this is an element of
surprise is all we're talking about one
you as a surprise one you're not if
you're surprised it's gonna throw you
off a little bit yeah if you're not
surprised you're braced for it you're
good to go yeah i mean i surprised
that's just one element of a different
context where you don't necessarily
expect so that's surprise and mental
preparation mental preparation is i
think the overarching because surprises
would fall under the mental preparation
i'm telling you that shower experience
kind of enlightened me a little bit
anyway okay
be comfortable with being uncomfortable
that's what jiu-jitsu saying too by the
way yeah is that where you heard him
mainly uh i don't
maybe that's where i first heard it yeah
because that's a good thing to have oh
yeah that's the that's the
backhanded compliment that hicks and
gracie told me when i rolled with him
back in the day what that you were
comfortable with he goes
he said you're very you're very
comfortable when you're in really bad
positions
and i was all happy yeah there you go he
was good at jiu jitsu yes so yeah that's
that's what i heard too
um but yeah so that's what it's just
saying so that means dude you did too
kind of really
that last stratagem or what what do you
call it rules general yeah yeah yeah is
essentially despised delicate living
yeah is jiu jitsu delicate living
no it is not it's not delicate but it's
not brutal
it depends who you roll with yeah that's
true
that's very true actually there's some
blood on the mat last night boy i
believe anyway jujitsu if if we're not
in jiu jitsu already we might not agree
on
the different mindsets for cold and all
that but we do agree do some jiu jitsu
and when you do it you're going to need
a ghee and what do you get
none other than the keys that are made
100 in america from top to bottom
from origin origin main
dot com that's where you get them you
can get whatever you want on there
and you can get rash guards so you can
do nogi as well and then you can get uh
t-shirts
and hoodies which are comfortable which
which
are the antithesis of what we're talking
about yes because you have claimed and
now this claim has been supported on
social media sites around the world
that the origin jogger pants which i
don't wear
are universally the most comfortable
pants of all time yes
yeah
still i mean and i went on searches like
my son got a pair for uh christmas cause
you know when you're in my family guess
what you're getting for christmas
product yeah yeah origin stuff
so he got a pair and i tried him on and
he was like you got to take them off
that's how they look because they just
don't because you don't match yeah they
just not they're not it's not me yeah
cause joggers as functional as they are
because they're super functional as far
as jogging and running goes um
as functional as they are they're that's
a style thing like they're in style
right yeah but they're somehow related
yeah to skinny jeans are they not yes
sir
that's the look yeah related so you yeah
bro you can't wear that kind of stuff
they used to issue and when i went when
i was at seal team two seal team one we
didn't have it so team two they issued
us
joggers but this is back in the day they
were basically like
they were basically like the same thing
because it was cold in the winter time
and guys would want to run with those
things on yeah but i didn't wear those
either
but everybody else can do it yeah yeah
wait and they're outer where they
weren't underwear you'd wear them like
over your
running shorts oh okay yeah cool there
you go yeah but these are these are
probably going to be way more
comfortable the ones from origin um and
they're made in america by the way i
don't know if i mentioned that but yeah
those are good job here's the thing you
despise comfort well i don't think you
despise comfort not as much as i should
yeah okay that makes sense to me i don't
despise comfort just like i don't
despise the rest between sets because
comfort is there for a reason
when you're kind of cold
i guess that's what i was going to say
earlier you enjoy comfort more when you
have discomfort yes right you don't want
to be the person that's constantly in a
feather pillow temperature controlled
scenario right yeah you want to be in
like the tough environment and then
you're like oh this feels good now yeah
like when you get out of the one you've
been surfing and it's cold
i went surfing the other day with no
wetsuit on and it's winter time here by
the way but one of my uh two actually of
my toes were numb straight up white how
so how cold is that maybe like what 55
yeah something like that yeah i mean i
only went for like 45 minutes
but yeah i was cold when i got done yeah
and then i went in the jacuzzi that was
nice and it felt good yes
so really did not despise that comfort
yes but it felt even better
than if it was just a normal day and i
wasn't didn't have a numb two toes yeah
so really it's more about
the ability to endure discomfort that's
really what it is so the the less time
you spend uncomfortable the less used to
it you'll be so the more like you know
the less capable you'll be of of
enduring it yeah kind of that's kind of
the thing yeah
check what they're going for anyway
[Music]
t-shirts joggers uh supplements
supplements of course joint supplements
which have shaken out to be the most
important supplements there are
that it's true or indeed for a semi to
moderate to highly active person that's
it yeah i know this firsthand definitely
uh so joint warfare krill oil
those are for your joints and for your
whole life like the stuff that's in
joint warfare
tumeric it has all kind it's not just
like yeah it's good for your joints but
it's good for a lot it's good for
everything yeah which is as i was
you know reading more about it oh no
there was an article that sprang up
that's what it was and i was like wow i
didn't know it did all this no wonder i
feel so good
anyways joint aware of her curl oil
discipline
there's also so discipline comes in
lemon lime which is tasty there's also
the new
tropic thunder
because we couldn't call it we couldn't
call it pina colada because that's just
not happening no no that wasn't just a
big negative
and then there's milk
of course
additional protein additional protein
that tastes delicious it tastes like a
dessert a for real dessert though yeah
and if you have kids or if you just
well if you have kids you get them
warrior kid molk
which
is the best possible thing you can buy a
child for food in my opinion yeah taste
well i guess if you get steak
sure i think i think vegetables are good
too i even like steak when i was a
little kid yeah you like burgers yeah i
liked burgers but
yeah you're more refined now it's
luxurious now yeah yeah
there was an acquired taste getting into
the steak thing huh yeah interesting
plus i had to learn how to cook it
better yeah so yeah warrior kid milk and
all that stuff from origin you can get
it origen maine.com
also
chocolate store it's called jocko store
so you go to chocolatestore.com and this
is where you can get
shirts
that represent the path i want to
represent discipline equals freedom this
one equals freedom shirt
here and this is what i realized this
cycle
i know i know i think maybe a little bit
too much into it but this happened
though
when you wear a discipline equals
freedom shirt to work out you like won't
skip the workout you'll be more into the
workout i notice that yeah because
you look and says discipline equals free
you know it's like you're representing
what it's actually saying it's not one
of these deals where it's like oh a cool
star on your shirt or something which is
cool there's people that have taken that
idea to the next level and gotten the
discipline equals freedom tattoos
see same exact concept and yeah man
i've seen it yeah like uh one dude has
the just michael's freedom i think it's
it's basically on the inside of his
wrist yeah try eating a doughnut with
that hand i know
exactly that's no way that's the exact
yeah if that happened you'd you'd be in
serious violation yeah like you couldn't
do it you'd feel it like you'd be doing
burpees for like yeah 45 minutes yeah
after that yeah yeah you've seen i
posted a picture of of the guy with it
on the inside yeah his arm yeah
no there's one guy that's in on his arm
are you talking about the one guy
there's a guy has on his wrist yeah
that's the one recently stamped yeah it
was that roll call yeah
that's when i took the picture but yeah
i saw that it was good see same exact
concept man yeah because yeah you can't
not represent now you know got the shirt
on boom you got the tattoo now you can
never not represent or are you going to
pay the price yeah to yourself by the
way you know so it's like a thing i dig
it man i did get respect
only get that tattoo
i think you should only get that tattoo
if you
if you're
you need to commit first right you need
to commit first and then get the tattoo
don't think that just the tattoo is
going to push you over the edge even
though i probably will even though
probably but maybe that's not the best
approach for tattoo uh decision making
is that so that's what you're saying
either way yeah anyway it's called
jackostore.com you can get your uh you
know the shirts and and
before you get the tattoo get the
t-shirt get the shirt first yeah get a
hat get a hat
if you're in the game cool then you can
step it up a little bit more hoodies yes
women's stuff i'm gonna have some new
stuff on there too
you keep saying that i know but you know
i'm gonna do it meanwhile is there
patches right now are we out of patches
um what
i don't know let me let me double check
i'm gonna check with the let me check
with the guy that's in charge of indian
toy oh wait that's you
well rest assured hey go
if you see something cool get something
if something's sold out or something
like that
i don't know let me know i guess don't
know you know what it won't be or it'll
be on the way either way it's called
jacostore.com a lot of cool stuff on
there if you want something you want to
represent in the wild in the wild by the
way
get something
also choco white tea on the store that
we saw that on the store too by the way
um but you can get this
yeah it's good you can get it from
amazon as well where else
guess what i'm drinking right now
hot tea yeah you know why comfortable
because it's a little bit cold though
all right see busted hey nah nah man it
yeah it makes sense you're weak you're
no stranger to the discomfort so i think
you're kind of you know whatever but
yeah chocolate white tea it's one of
those uh deals where even if you don't
like tea that much you'll probably like
this one it doesn't
it tastes like tea but it doesn't taste
like tea can i say that does that make
any sense you know if you drink it that
makes a dichotomy
but there's no dichotomy in the factory
was teaching the the
jiu jitsu class at the muster and he
used the word dichotomy and then
everyone started laughing yeah because
the way he says it is like directly
directly mocking me yeah using the word
dichotomy
yeah
so yeah so yeah jacques t outstanding uh
stuff
makes you deadlift eight thousand pounds
but we already knew that yeah everyone
knows that yeah yeah worldwide deadlift
has increased a lot yup also
it's in cans
which is good for me because the whole
brewing tea uh uh sequence uncomfortable
isn't very uncomfortable for me yes so
you know can seems more cool but
whatever whatever you like also
subscribe to this podcast if you haven't
already uh on you know wherever you
listen to podcasts there it is i know i
i don't think we even need to say that
anymore okay we i've said that for like
a year or maybe even three years that we
don't need to say to subscribe to the
podcast but we do need to say subscribe
to the warrior kid podcast
yes check it out
check it out even if you
aren't a kid
check it out
i use a different voice in that podcast
dave burke was talking about it yeah
he's like i even like that different
i use this voice right here it's a
little bit more aimed at kids yeah this
is just the way i normally talk
when i do because i'm kind of uncle jake
in that uncle jake is a little bit more
he's not he's
well not dorky but he just doesn't have
his a little bit of a dark side like i
do yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good way of
putting it the dark edge he's just good
he's like uncle jake is just good across
the board yeah you never know what i
might have a little
i might have a little
issue with something and get kind of
crazy on it yeah uncle jake's not going
to let that happen so check out the
warrior kid podcast
if you want to get some more information
to your kids
about being on the path
and you can hear me
talk and tell stories
in this voice
from uncle jake
yeah
actually sounded actually exactly like
how you sound on it which is good
anyway also yes youtube as well so we do
have a youtube channel if you didn't
know that it does have the video version
of this podcast and also little excerpts
and enhanced excerpts by the way i was
noticing some of your recent excerpts
you can't make excerpts that are 12
minutes long that's not an excerpt
that's just like a video well
technically that's that's not correct
because an excerpt is just a part okay
no time limit but here's the thing with
the 12 12 minutes is long man i know and
sometimes they're gonna be 12 minutes
there's no way that everything in that
12 minutes is important
kind yeah that's true okay but you put
out your editing scissors
depends on how you look at it though bro
these things are supposed to be an
excerpt should be like ah you know what
boom
two minutes and 28 seconds later you're
like yeah i got this oh i dig it i agree
but not a lot of times you want people
to pull up a couch and heave in for well
some of us watch it
some of us are on the computer doing
other stuff
and then boom there the excerpt comes up
you know about maybe or maybe it's like
you saying something and me disagreeing
and then you say well this is this and
i'm saying well that's true but what
about this you're like okay or whatever
you know it's like a little it's like a
little conversation that's not two hours
see i'm saying cool so you know it's
presentable it's good do it okay so
there's there's on the youtube channel
there's long and short excerpts yes
there's digestible
and there's a little bit more like you
know
meal time
conversational
uh you know because it's less about like
the shortness and shareability
necessarily it's more about like hey
remember share ability oh like i can you
watch it yeah like okay if there's a
minute yeah they're more likely to watch
the minute video than the 12 minute
video but
the 12 minute is like the kind of like
if you just want to hear about like this
specific like topic that happened to
take 12 they're not all 12 minutes no
it's like one
that's maybe like eight minutes though
maybe six
either way yeah
psychological warfare too speaking of
little excerpts those are just short
short one to two minutes
of how to overcome some type of
momentary weakness that you might have
if you don't have a discipline equals
freedom tattoo on your wrist that's
going to keep you in check
the this is another thing you can do
prior to getting that tattoo you can
just
load up your psychological warfare on
itunes google play mp3 platforms
whatever and listen to those yes which
is
jaco telling you how to overcome the
weakness
that is that's that tattoo on your wrist
discipline equals freedom is like the
ultimate psychological warfare it is a
weapon it is a good weapon like boom
just swinging oh what if you put
discipline on one wrist and freedom on
the other wrist
i actually might do that that's pretty
good that's pretty good discipline feed
them
origin
i've been talking to pete we're trying
to buy a machine
that can make
sweat bands wrist bands
right and then once we have that power
two things number one i'm gonna make the
best
wristbands because i wear wristbands
every time i work out yeah and
but there's no good wristbands in the
world there's none of them that meet the
standards that i would like them to meet
why do you wear spins uh sweat primarily
oh so it doesn't go on your hands
because the sweater will run right down
my arms and my hands and i'm just
dropping everything and it sucks yeah
premiere so
uh
i'm gonna make wristbands that are super
long
right and really like just
i told people like we can put discipline
on one and freedom on the other one
right and you can buy a little set
yeah so anyways pete's pete's shopping
for the machine right now good cake
socks
yes it can make socks pete sent me a
picture of a machine
and he goes what do you think this makes
and i looked at it and i don't know i
just kind of like logically it was sort
of like a um
you could see stuff 360 degrees around
something else
and i was like i bet you i said socks
and he goes damn
because i'm not in the industry right
but you can recognize he was impressed
with my logic yeah your d
deductive skills yeah yeah it's good i'm
impressed too
speaking of being impressed go to on it
so on it the company i'm impressed with
always have been by the way so go to
onit.com this is where you can get
kettlebells all kinds of cool workout
equipment that you can just slowly add
to your arsenal at home if you've got a
home gym whatever really good stuff on
there also good info on there
so you know if you want to educate
yourself a little bit more boom that's
the place to go on it.com jocko really
good stuff on there really good we got
some books we got mikey in the dragons
which is fully in stock
really yeah it ran a little low
we almost didn't make christmas but we
made it thank god cool thanks to
everyone on the team that helped us and
all the printers around that that
printed us copies and we got a bunch of
copies and everyone got them by
christmas that i know of everyone that's
reached out on twitter that said it's
not here yet on december
19th or 13th was like we still don't
have it i ordered october i was like
it's coming please comment
and uh but as far as i know everyone got
them when they
they got them in time
for christmas so um now we have a lot
so if you want to get mikey in the
dragons best children's book ever
ever yep yeah
yeah disagree with me no
well i think just by nature i'm like
whoa you just made a claim let me like
refute it so i'm all thinking but hey
man i geek because obviously
i would be like hey what about this way
that we're a kid because i thought that
was kids
what age group for which okay
young best was it a toddler that reads
mikey in the dragons
toddler reads mike and the dragons
toddler best toddler someone they can
walk
yeah
yeah well some callers can't understand
best
children's book picture book with
for ages five and under sure seven and
six and under sure mikey and the dragons
there okay we broke that down order that
weigh the warrior kid when the kids get
a little bit older order way the warrior
kid in mark's mission book three has
been written i got pictures from john
bozak today via text you saw him right
witnessed yes yeah how do you like him
we like him a lot i showed i showed
danny reinhart to my youngest daughter
and i've been i've been i've been
telling her about danny reinhart for a
long time because danny reinhart does
everything perfect and danny reinhart
does everything good and mark's kind of
jealous of him
and i should and she was she's been she
got all into the name
danny reinhardt yeah she's annoyed with
them yeah she's already doesn't like him
yeah but the the interesting twist on
the story is danny reinhardt's actually
a good kid yeah and he just happens to
be talented and he happens to work hard
and he's actually nice
but mark's jealous
so warrior kid three coming out in the
spring and right now we got warrior kid
1 and warrior kid 2 mark's mission
also got this one equals freedom field
manual
the manual for getting after it yeah in
life
super stoked on everyone that's posting
uh pictures and us i'm actually most
stoked when somebody posts a picture
that they've lost 162 pounds
yes in 14 months or whatever
completely changed their lives yeah why
discipline equals freedom so
you can get that book for yourself
that's also pre-tattoo
maybe before you get the tattoo you just
leave this out on your uh coffee table
yeah right yeah you just have it there
because it's looking at you that book is
looking at you yeah i got a stack of
them in my room i feel them oh yeah yeah
they they they keep me right on yeah
so if you want if you want the audio
version it's on itunes amazon music
google play other mp3 platforms
obviously extreme ownership the first
book that i wrote with my brother leif
babin taking the lessons that we learned
on the battlefield
and explaining how they can be applied
to your business and to your life and
that was the followed up that was
followed up by the book that we just had
come up out called the dichotomy of
leadership
and this
is getting granular in how to apply
those leadership principles
into your world
also we have echelon front which is uh
my leadership consultancy
and what we do is solve problems through
leadership if you have any kind of
problem
in your organization
it is a leadership problem
we will help get your leadership fixed
get them aligned and get them working
and get the team functioning properly we
also have a leadership conference
that we do
it's called the muster in 2019 there are
three musters may 23rd and 24th in
chicago september 19th and 20th in
denver and december 4th and 5th in
sydney australia
check out extremeownership.com for the
details and to register all of them that
we have done have sold out this is and
what i'm saying they sold out this is
when people call me up and say or like
people that i know yeah say hey
hey i know we're a little late just
wanna can you just um can you just
reserve three seats for me and you know
these two other people that i work with
and i'm like
actually no i can't
you cannot come
well we'll just stand in the back no
there's fire codes like you can't come
yeah everyone thinks you all just you
know no yeah it's sold out
so you can't come the
the um
the live podcast we're doing
january 9th
sold out immediately it's like sorry
gotta be quick on those i guess
so there's that now we do have this ef
online this is this is the interactive
training leadership training that we put
together and
okay so there's several
places where this stem from
one of them is the muster itself because
guess what the muster is great
foundational
information it's a great
foundational leadership
um instruction that you're gonna get
when you go not everyone can make it to
the muster so what we did is we took the
content from the first like two musters
that we did and this is the fundamental
principles from extreme ownership from
the economy leadership we took those
and put them into interactive online
training
so that people that couldn't make it to
the muster could still get that training
we also did it because companies that
we work with sometimes they have
10 000 employees 20 000 employees 100
000 employees
and all the employees are not all in one
place they're all over the place they're
all over the
country and they're all over the world
how are we going to train all those
people we what we needed to do is figure
out a way to scale the training that we
did there was many requests from the
larger companies we worked with to get
the training
to all their employees how do we do that
we had to scale it so we put it online
and then once we put it online for
companies we figured okay let's get it
out there for direct to consumers that
want to take the training they can't
come to the muster what have you or they
want to get reminded what they learned
at the muster same thing
so that's
online training it's available now
at ef online.com
also we've got ef overwatch where we are
taking
leadership gaps in the civilian sector
and we are filling those leadership gaps
with
trained
and experienced and tested leaders from
combat aviation and from the spec ops
community go to
efoverwatch.com regardless of which side
of that equation you're on whether
you're a company that needs leaders or
whether you're a vet that's seeking a
leadership position in a company
go to eforewatch.com
and fill out the information that
applies to you
and if you want to continue this
conversation with us
we can be found all up in the interwebs
on instagram
on twitter
and on the facebook
keyboard echo is at echo charles and i
am at jocko willing and finally to all
our military personnel out there thank
you for
protecting freedom around the world and
to our folks in uniform here at home
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts correctional officers
border patrol
all first responders
thanks for protecting us and our
families
and everyone else out there
remember
that discipline is stronger than fury
you need a little bit of fury
you need a little bit of discipline you
need to combine those things
but you take that discipline and you
impose discipline upon yourself
and reject and refuse
delicate living and the luxuries that
are available to you in life and instead
get out of that comfort
and make yourself better faster smarter
and stronger by going out there day
after day after day
and getting after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out